hey freya how are you doing
good thank you
don't tell the rest of the cast but
series hands down my favorite character
of season two thank you thank you so
much i just better not find out that
you've told everyone that i swear i
didn't tell anyone else i'm recorded i
wouldn't be that silly um but i just i
love siri so much because we just get to
learn
so much more about her plus she's a
badass with a sword how much fun were
all those training scenes for you
so much fun yeah there was a lot of um
adrenaline and um
yeah it was it was just like it was so
nice actually just to be taken away for
a moment from all these really heavy
emotionally intense scenes to just be
kind of like focusing on my body and
physic physicality and not getting hit
by a giant flying boulder
yeah that's nice having a break from
that right that can be a little intense
such an exciting part about
season two and so entertaining for us to
watch is this daughter-father
relationship between geralt and siri and
the fact that siri just doesn't listen
to carol
a lot how much fun was that for you
playing that off with henry
um
yeah i mean it was it was an interesting
dynamic to play with i mean i i also
think that geralt doesn't listen to siri
a lot cause i think
she you know she's expressing how she
feels
and you know he's not really he's so
focused on his priority of protecting
her that he's not actually listening to
her own desires and her own wants as a
human being rather than just this
person to protect and to keep away from
this person and to keep hidden from that
person and to not get her and blah blah
blah she wants to be something herself
rather than just
just that you know um and i think she's
trying to discover her identity and i
think um
you know eventually that messages sort
of like got across to geralt but i think
there's definitely that kind of
i don't know they're both not listening
to each other you know it's a bit of a
knocking of head situation absolutely um
you know
both these characters are are obviously
destined to be together um
but in season one you didn't really get
to to work a whole lot with henry so
what was it like working with him so
much then in season two
yeah it was um it was
anticipated for me because
season one i
i i thought but when i got the role that
i would have tons of scenes with him
because i read blood of elves and
obviously in that book i do but then
obviously i discovered i had one scene
with him so it was really nice to to
finally get to work with him and um
i think similarly to our characters we
really built up a kind of team and a
trust with one another so yeah it was a
lot of fun
what are you excited for the fans to see
when it comes to season two because
season one obviously has this fan base
of the books and the games but it became
this massive phenomenon around the world
people were just so in love with these
characters and these story lines what
are you excited for them to see with
season two
um with regards to siri i'm just excited
for them to see more of the story that
they actually sort of
um were waiting for it with with season
one you know i think season one didn't
give siri justice and i think in season
two she's really fleshed out we really
get to go into what she's experiencing
and
and also obviously all the physical
training element as well um but also
just in regards to the whole season just
new characters that i think is a lot of
fun you know these characters that are
introduced uh
um
really serve a great purpose and um
bring a lot to the series and uh i love
getting to work with the new actors as
well and yeah i'm really excited for
for everyone to see them and the new you
know relationships built yeah well i
can't wait for everyone to see this
season and your character and and how
she's evolved so thanks so much congrats
thank you thanks a lot yeah
you